[Music]
foreign
for me like Adam was the only uh he was
like the only artist that I knew you
know like growing up and and you know uh
he was older and he was um it's just
like so incredible man like just you you
know like
we would you know we would always sell
they've celebrated Christmas and we all
celebrated Christmas and Christmas was
totally right yeah yeah but like you
know they they uh
you know I just remember from the
youngest age he was like he could play
any song on any instrument and I
remember like sitting down with him he
he I got the synthesizer when I was in
fourth grade and we like he started like
playing this song he like taught me
these three chords and we started we
made up the song together it's like
she's mysterious and was like I'm
walking through the night the girl is
out of sight because she's mysterious
I've never seen that before but like we
like made that up to it he was like you
could that's how easy it is man and I
was like what no like like it was Matt
like he was magic but I also remember
um
you know with like an older cousin like
that you know there it's just like it's
very much like you're always like in all
of them you know and he was like so
successful he was like Stacy's mom came
out you were probably like 18 or
something yeah yeah and but like even
even before like just being in a band
and like right like you know he wrote
that thing you do and then and uh and
like you know I wanted to be an actor
and he was like he had like a PL like a
place in in New York you know like and
he it was like he was just so you know
far away and Untouchable and and godly
to me
um it's so funny because he's such a
like regular guy he was such a regular
guy I can't believe I did that thing
that people do like on Law and Order
when it's like she's
she was
you go like nobody does that and then I
was like oh I guess people do this yeah
but like uh I was always like really
hesitant I never reached out to him I
never was like hey can you help me with
it like I remember one time I like
needed a place to stay I was like you
know for a while in New York I was I was
like I was living in my I was I had a
Jeep I was living in my Jeep but it was
I didn't have a top and it was raining
but I wouldn't I couldn't like bring
myself to like Ascot who had this like
beautiful place I couldn't like bring
myself to be like hey man can I like
stay there and then like in later years
like anything you need he was just like
that he's so kind and um you know what I
think probably similarly like you you
you you were
I think much closer with him than even I
was weirdly and I get it yeah you know
and that's but I'm just like wondering
because like you probably were
like you probably weren't at a place
where you could fight with him you know
what I mean no but like no we would
fight you know like you know what I mean
like I mean can you just explain a
little bit about like your guys I mean
who knows like whatever who knows if
this is but just for me I'm just really
interested about your relationship with
him and who who like kind of we started
working together like making weird
videos he had an idea for like a JLo
video but it's about like staying home
like about going to a party but instead
it's about staying home and masturbating
and watching TV and I was like yeah I
love it because we had this mutual
friend Daniel kellison and so we made
some videos we did stuff he wrote the
theme song to Crank Yankers which was a
like show we do a long time ago but he
read my book and he came over my
apartment he's like this is a musical
and he's like reading the chapter titles
that's a song you know I was just like
all right you know and we just started
writing it together and and
um
we just really had a good
working relation I always think it's a
great creative relationship when you can
fight and there's no love loss it's like
we would fight and we would never walk
away mad we would like fight until we
were dying laughing and both loved the
idea you know yeah but I always think
that's special when you can like go you
know I mean there were times where I was
like
literally Over My Dead Body are we doing
that you know what I mean but then then
like by the end it's like yeah that is
that's good but
um but I always feel close to people
that I can
butt heads with without worrying that
there's any love lost or anything and we
were good at that and you know he was
like
um
you know he he was
um what's it called not hard-headed you
know pit uh stubborn yeah
he was stubborn and it's funny because
I'm used to working with people you know
we're artists you know like and we're
working at with this theater and he was
so impatient because we're used to TV
like he wrote song he wrote like three
songs a week for Crazy Ex-Girlfriend
like he wants he's like I want a
deadline I want to know when The Show
Goes Up I wanna and like theater it's
like it took 10 years ultimately you
know but he's like give us a date
there's ridiculous we can get this done
we're almost there and I remember them
calling me
to talk about Adam oh really yeah and
they're like well I mean he's just you
know I mean uh we you know he he got all
met I was just like I couldn't believe
it I go don't you guys work with artists
like I can't believe you're
at like clenching your per like
clutching your pearls like he just you
know like he would be very passionate
about something I I would say like I'm
not gonna respond to you for one week
you have to sit with this for one week
you know and then you'd be like yeah
right or like he would go I want this to
happen now and it probably would have
been good but like instead we had to do
like two workshops and by the end of it
I go do you wish we went up before the
workshops or you like it better now I
like it better now you know but like
it's so it was just so funny to me and
of course they love him they loved you
know but but they were like oh well I
mean he just like he he blew up at the
and go are you really upset about that
like he's Stardust like he's not gonna
bite he's yeah he's just Adam like yeah
but they would like be like you're the
Adam whisperer no I'm not I'm just a
person who's not
overreacting yeah like but he was so
funny we laughed so hard we worked so
well together and and the truth you know
I'm talking about like his like creative
stuff but I mean he was a doll you know
he was a love and it's funny because
before covet hit we started hanging out
not working like just hanging out he he
would come out here and he had this I
still have it in my phone and as a
matter of fact it's in my phone for
today which like every like second
Friday of the month he would have his
piano piano bar like a karaoke piano bar
that he co-owns that that would do like
a um pop-up here in LA and we went to
New York right here in New York he's got
he had Sid gold right and here they had
um gold diggers and it was like one
night a month and I started going to
because it was so fun and I'm not a
karaoke person but we would both like go
up and it's so fun just like in New York
it's like all professional singers and
it's so fun cheering everyone on yeah
so we were like really hanging out you
know and um did did his death like did
that did that kind of I mean for us it's
sort of like at least in the beginning
it like just framed covet in like a
totally different yeah
I still kind of don't believe it like I
just
um I just don't believe yeah it's it's
very grief is a funny thing isn't it you
can't control it you know it's like it's
so weird I haven't cried and then like
two weeks later you're in line at
Gelson's and you're like
I know like it's just it it it does its
own thing and you have to just let it
you know but yeah but it's so weird and
the show happened right you know and
it's he it's just maddening yeah
and it's also
it just happened so quick he was texting
us like oh can you believe this can you
believe it I'm in the hospital with a
[__] code like me on a ventilator
yeah
just wild you know to at that time you
know and you you know in the in the
beginning of the house he couldn't find
he couldn't get a test and then he
finally found a test and then he never
got there they just never sent the
results you know it's just so early on
like if it had just happened sure
anyway I mean there's nothing it just
happened that's what this is what is
yeah but
but boy when the play went up it's just
he is all over it yeah you know it's in
you know the family came and everything
and and it really felt like a
celebration of Adam this show even
though it's about media room 10. it's
just it's so signature him
so it was that was nice but it's it's
frustrating but you kind of have to let
it go because it's just it's not going
to change for sure for sure I'm telling
you you know I mean obviously no but
yeah yeah
[Music]
I'm gonna get a workout in a little bit
with my man Eric Linden stunt
coordinator from The Punisher he's
coming all the way up because we're
about to get after it and when that's
done he asked me in the car are you
gonna have my shake ready and I know
what that means am I gonna have my son
Warrior Shake they've got the active
protein but they also have this collagen
protein which is amazing they also have
the warrior blend which is a little bit
lighter if you're trying to cut and uh I
believe in it I believe in that some
Warrior stuff go to
www.sunwarrior.com
real ones for 15 off I appreciate y'all
foreign